imagine that a doctor is sitting across
the table from you you're just meeting
this doctor for the first time you're
not sure whether she's a good doctor or
a bad doctor you can't tell if she has
any morals or not you're assessing
things
and then the doctor tells you about one
of the highlights of her year with a
smile on her face she starts talking
about one time a few months ago when she
killed a clown we're talking about a man
dressed in full clown uniform a red nose
who was giggling when he died it was
really important for him to be in his
clown suit when he died the doctor says
to you it was a wonderful thing
at a basic human level how would you
react to that scenario would you run out
of the doctor's office and call the
police
or would you congratulate the doctor
because you're also a murderer who hates
clowns
what would you do at this point you're
probably thinking yourself well what's
with all the hypothetical questions this
is crazy I mean what are the odds I'm
going to be sitting face to face with a
clown killing doctor
as it happens if you live in Canada it's
not a hypothetical at all meet Dr
Stephanie Green she's one of the
country's leading physicians in the area
of medical assistance in dying or made
and she recently sat down for an
interview in which she talks about
um the one time that she deliberately
killed a clown now I want you to watch
the interviewer ask her about this and
listen to her response notice the grins
on these people's faces as they describe
the death of this poor clown watch
one of these I absolutely loved was um I
mean I have to admit to uh welling up
several times while reading the book
about Ed
um who was an amateur clown
and I think and he was having you were
going to be administering his assisted
death and I think he must have left the
room or something or he he left the room
and came back uh Dressed in his full
clown regalia including a red nose and
um and you asked him what what what that
was about you know why was it and he
said that he wanted to go out laughing
um and I just thought that was so
Charming but but it does lead into the
fact that from talking to you and other
practitioners
um
it's become sort of socially accepted
now that people are having assisted
deaths everyone is so individual and
what's important to one person may not
be as important or differently or you
know important to someone else so for Ed
it was really important that he be in
his clown suit and you know have this
atmosphere uh you know with him at this
final moment and somebody else might
find that ridiculous but there's a
there's a real Beauty in recognizing
that for for Ed this was key and it was
such a wonderful thing to be able to
facilitate this with Ed you know for
someone else like you say it might be an
event with champagne
a wonderful thing to facilitate with the
clouds usually when you talk about
facilitating something with a clown
you're talking about uh inviting a clown
to a birthday party let's say uh but in
this case she's talking about
facilitating his execution
that's one of the creepiest videos
you'll ever see but it's The Cutting
Edge of state-run medicine in Canada
they are killing people and they are
celebrating it
before we really get into things let's
uh let's review a few points first in
Canada
doctors do not just execute the
terminally ill as awful as that alone
would be thanks to a recent court
decision and a new law in Canada doctors
can kill pretty much anyone
watch the creepy clown killing doctor
explain the standard of care that
determines who is actually eligible for
execution now watch
our law never required terminal illness
it never required a prognosis of six
months it always required originally
that the patient be on a trajectory
towards their natural death with no time
limit around that allowing more of a
flexible clinical interpretation but
that that on even even that was
challenged because that wasn't in our
original uh constitutional decision by
The Carter case and so
for
three or four years after the law was
passed it was looked at in a Provincial
Court and it was decided that also
needed to be struck out of the law and
with the removal of that it opened up uh
access to assisted dying for those who
weren't uh necessarily dying
a trajectory towards death is already an
incredibly permissive standard for youth
euthanasia given the fact that we as
mortal creatures are all on a trajectory
towards death
I hate to tell you but even that vague
limitation has been lifted now there's
basically no limitation at all
and that's why last year a Canadian
doctor named Joshua Tapper was able to
authorize the killing of a 23 year old
man named Keanu and why was Keanu killed
well according to the sub stack Common
Sense Keanu was depressed he was
diabetic and he had lost one Vision
Vision in one eye and on top of that he
quote didn't have a girlfriend on those
grounds alone the doctor authorized the
state to kill Keanu
there are many more stories like this
there's Amir farsood who was approved
for maid because he was homeless there's
the Army veteran Christine Gauthier who
was told by the Canadian government to
consider euthanasia rather than endure
the weight for a stair lift in her home
and so on many cases like this
now this is eugenics it's the kind of
thing the medical community thought long
and hard about after World War II
doctors wondered you know how do we make
sure that medicine is never again used
to kill the weakest and least desirable
members of society well doctors no
longer asked that question
Eugenics is making a comeback
why is that
if you look at this as a purely
political issue it makes sense several
years ago Canadian politicians realized
that they had a big problem the Health
Care system which they run
wasn't able to keep up with the need for
organ donors it's a big big political
problem thousands of people were dying
waiting for transplants so the
government set out to find new ways to
get more organs and that's when they
passed the first law legalizing
euthanasia
now if you think it sounds crazy to make
this connection well the Canadian media
Drew this connection immediately here's
a headline from the Ottawa Citizen in
2020 a few years after made was
legalized quote medically assisted
deaths provide a proof a growing Boon to
organ donation in Ontario
very quickly Canada became the world's
leader in harvesting organs from made
victims according to the American
Journal of transplantation doctors in
Canada perform almost half of the
world's organ transplants from made and
they've done that over the past half
decade
Ontario sets new records for organ
donations every year
so that's one political problem solved
just like China harvests organs from
prisoners Canada Harvest them from
homeless people and the elderly
euthanasia also solves financial
problems back in 2017 the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation ran an article
raving about all the money the country
could save by simply killing sick people
outright you know to to take care of
sick people is expensive but if you kill
them then you save a bunch of money it
turns out quote new research suggests
medically assisted dying could result in
substantial savings across Canada's
Health Care System doctor-assisted death
could reduce annual Health Care spending
across the country by between 34.7
million dollars and 136.8 million the
savings exceedingly outweigh the
estimated 1.5 to 14.8 million in direct
costs associated with implementing
medically assisted dying
the article goes on to explain that it's
very expensive to provide medical care
to sick people and elderly people the
more frugal option is to give them a
lethal injection problem solved
who cares about human life anyway when
there's money to be saved
money to be saved
and money to be made the euthanasia
industry is booming in Canada with
entrepreneurs finding new and creative
ways to get in on the action as the CBC
excitedly reported funeral homes are
expanding their brands to include
medical assistance and dying customers
can now take the advantage take
advantage of the luxury sort of a full
service option
which means that instead of going to a
funeral home after you die you can go
there to die
think of the convenience watch
welcome follow me funeral homes have
been in Metro Baker's family for
Generations but he recently expanded the
kind of service he offers so this is the
room where you have the Medical Aid and
dying yes this is this is where it it
happens people who are approved for
medical assistance and dying can come
here with their doctor and loved ones to
end their lives at a cost of at least
seven hundred dollars it's a lot of
organization
on on our part to really make it a
respectful and meaningful event for the
for that family it's what Michelle
Brunell recently opted for his family
says he had emphysema and his quality of
life had deteriorated but he didn't want
to die at home or in the hospital
they're using a room that they have
already
decorated it very nicely allowed us to
the time we needed to do what we had to
do to say goodbye let him get
comfortable
uh it's just it's just a beautiful
option
[Music]
suicide rooms in funeral homes
this is real this is actually happening
right now
you know and if you really want to
increase efficiency maybe they can even
allow you to commit suicide while laying
in your casket
saving time saving money making money
that's what Eugenics has always been
about the CEO of innovation refunds and
getrefunds.com has been on TV explaining
how they've helped so many small
businesses with their ERC tax refunds
they've completed thousands of returns
for different kinds of businesses
including over 700 million dollars for
construction companies and over 200
million dollars in restaurants bars and
hotels Innovation refunds has hundreds
of five-star trust pilot in Google
reviews it's certified with the Better
Business Bureau in just eight minutes
you can easily start the process on
getrefunds.com you could be up on your
way to um receiving up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee the ERC
tax credit it's not a loan it's a refund
of your already paid taxes it's designed
to let the business owner direct the
refund money into anything the business
needs to grow it's money that you can
use to improve your business however you
see fit so go to getrefunds.com to start
the process there's no upfront charge
you don't get paid or they don't get
paid until you get paid Innovation
refunds has already helped clients claim
over five billion dollars in payroll tax
refunds through the ERC and they may be
able to help your business too so go to
getrefunds.com or download the app from
the app store today that's
getrefunds.com today you know the first
step in uh growing up and being a real
man is getting off your parents phone
plan getting your own cell phone plan
gives you a sense of Independence and
responsibility to step towards becoming
more self-sufficient by paying for your
own finances you learn how to budget and
manage your money there are a ton of
cell phone providers out there
unfortunately most of them want to lock
you into these contracts they'll tack on
hidden fees at any chance they get
that's why I'm a big fan of pure talk
there are no contracts no hassles you
can cancel at any time it's very simple
Pure Talk is also giving you a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy phone
when you sign up for the 55 per month
unlimited plan plus hotspot today they
use the same Nationwide networks as
major carries so you get all the same
coverage that you do but a lot cheaper a
lot easier switching over to Pure Talk
is so easy you can make the switch keep
your cell phone keep your phone number
with their Us customer service team you
can make the switch in as little as 10
minutes Pure Talk is so sure you're
going to love your service that they're
backing it up with a 100 money back
guarantee so go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Walsh just say 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code walls Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
that's obviously not the entire
explanation for what we're seeing every
country has evil politicians who would
kill innocent people for power but
Canada has much bigger problems and its
main problem is that it's a Godless
hellhole one that's so far gone the
Prime Minister makes excuses for church
burnings
Canadians they don't believe in God
anymore at least not in the traditional
sense they believe that they are gods
they think that they can change their
sex just by wishing for it God doesn't
choose whether you're male or female you
get to choose it and you could change
your sex in literally an instant
that's what they seriously believe it's
whatever one on the left believes so
it's only natural that a society like
that would gradually assume more
god-like Powers including the power to
decide who dies and when they die
and just like with gender ideology made
is becoming a social media cult in
Canada kids with obvious mental problems
are posting tick tocks with captions
like things my parents have had to come
to terms with their child choosing
medical assistance and dying
now if we put the picture up on the
screen and you just take a look at this
person
your first reaction is that you know if
you're a sane human being your first
reaction is that whoever that is some
sort of mental health intervention is
obviously necessary for this person
but very quickly that's becoming the
minority position
notice the 26 000 likes on that post
okay this is a young girl talking about
how she's going to kill herself and 26
000 people liked it
by the way that girl who just yesterday
set her uh Tick Tock account to private
has posted many times about her
intention to take advantage of the maid
program
she says that she says that she has a
chronic medical condition note not
terminal but chronic and she also says
that she has three quote incurable
personality disorders so to be to be
clear
doctors are going to kill this girl
because in part
her personality is disordered
there's many more social media posts
like that here's a video of a woman
celebrating that a physician is about to
kill her grandmother watch
I came in quietly
are you nervous are you excited how do
you feel good just putting an end to
being dependent no control so as the day
approaches is it something you're
thinking about every day or no just it's
gonna happen when it happens yeah and
I'll be ready I'll know
are you excited Grandma about your
suicide
that was the question
and this is about as dark as it gets
and once again these are not one-off
videos millions of people support this
and not just on social media more than
25 percent of Canadians in a poll now
believe that the homeless and the poor
should be able to access made nearly
half of respondents think mental illness
should be a justification for euthanasia
and that's about to be law in Canada
it's expected to be implemented in one
year
um NPR would like to see that happen
they just ran a segment on someone named
John Scully who wants to die uh because
of his mental illness listen
the expansion of medical assistance in
dying to people with mental illness has
been delayed by Canada's parliament for
another year the country already allows
medically assisted death for some
incurable illnesses but as Emma Jacobs
reports mental health conditions are
still up for debate please note this
story does include discussion of suicide
for John Scully life has literally
become a living nightmare when I wake up
I go oh god I've got to stop it I've got
to stop it I must find a way to stop it
Scully lives in Toronto he was diagnosed
with depression more than 30 years ago
and suffers from work-related PTSD and
anxiety he says he has terrible Vivid
nightmares there is no way to stop it
and because of that I'm also permanently
sleep deprived he has been watching the
progress of the expansion of medical
assistance and dying known by its
acronym made very closely I actually
physically got the paperwork for me is I
have it right here Canada's medical
assistance and dying program was made
legally available to some adults with
terminal illness in 2016. in 2021 it was
expanded to include those suffering with
serious and chronic physical conditions
but for many the plan to extend this to
those suffering with solely mental
illness raised concerns we don't have
very good ways of defining incurability
for mental health problems
did you catch that so they just need to
figure out which mental illnesses are
incurable
and once I figure that out then they'll
know which ones should be cured with
suicide this will be a reality soon
enough
suicide offered as a treatment for
mental illness
now it used to be that you would go to a
therapist to help you not kill yourself
in Canada very soon it may work the
other way
and when you consider that 20 of adults
supposedly have a mental illness
according to the people who are in
charge of determining these things
anyway you begin to see how Bleak this
picture really is if mental illness is a
legitimate reason to execute somebody
then pretty soon we're all going to be
eligible
now it's been easy for many people in
this country to ignore made because for
the most part it's happening in Canada
but euthanasia is growing in popularity
here too in fact just this month the U.S
got its very first suicide tourism State
the Republican Governor Vermont signed a
bill allowing euthanasia customers to
come from anywhere in the country to be
killed
they'll start putting that in their
tourism ads hey you want to kill
yourself come to Vermont and do it
as always culturally we're on the same
track and on the same train as Canada
heading over the same Cliff we're just
maybe a few train cars back
as I said on Twitter the other day um I
should not have to explain
nobody should have to explain
why it's bad for doctors to put human
beings down like dogs this is something
that everybody should understand
intuitively if you don't understand it
intuitively there's something wrong with
you and you need to think about that
because whatever you think of suicide
and if you have a soul then what you
think what you should think of suicide
is that it's bad and we should try to
stop people from doing it
the point with euthanasia is that
doctors are prescribing death as a
treatment
it is a total inversion of the medical
field it is medicine doing literally the
exact opposite of what it is meant to do
but medicine has been inverted in this
way in our society for a long time
euthanasia is just the latest iteration
some of us have noticed this trend some
of us the so-called social conservatives
have been screaming about it from the
rooftops for a long time and we've been
right all along
we have been right on every major
cultural issue from abortion to gay
marriage to gender ideology
and we're right about this too
euthanasia is a dystopian Abomination it
is a war on human life it is a Cancer
and like any cancer it will never stay
contained it will never stop it always
spreads it starts with euthanasia for
the terminally ill and very quickly it
becomes euthanasia for 19 year old girls
with personality disorders
this is inevitable it will always be
this way
if you accept medical assistance in
dying in principle
you are accepting everything that comes
with it and everywhere that it leads
how long until maid is mandatory for
certain undesirable populations in
Canada
how long until it's mandatory here
now you can laugh at that slippery slope
hypothetical if you want
but the thing about slippery slope
hypotheticals is that these days they
have a funny habit of coming true
and I'll do it for this part of the show
as we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed